councillors
welcome to this
meeting of the central platte area
planning on wednesday the 20th of
october 2021. my name is councillor
stilts and i'm chairman of this
committee before we commence the
business of the meeting there are a few
housekeeping issues to run through
members the set up for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for kobe
therefore can i ask you all to present
to work to the protocols agreed at
council on 2nd september 2021 in the
interest of member and officer safety
we are streaming this meeting live and
as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate you
wish to speak and i will invite you at
the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent upon the
correct use of microphones therefore
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and turn it off when
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda items keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda paper regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit door is
the door behind this top table
item two on the agenda may i have
apologies for absence tara
yes chairman thank you apologies been
received from councillor miss beale and
councillor edwards thank you german
thank you
item number three on the agenda it is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 25th of august 2021
found on pages 7 to 12 are approved as a
true and accurate record i so do move do
i have a second of that motion thank you
counselor maze
our members happy to take that by ascent
thank you
declarations of interest item four to
disclose the excuse existence of
a nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interest other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
of items related
to business on the
in
agenda
to paragraph six to eight inclusive of
the code of conduct for members members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interests as soon
as they should become aware and should
the need rise throughout the meeting do
i have any declarations of interest
no thank you
we moved to item 5 on the agenda found
on pages 13 to
32. which is 20 0 0 3 3 9 4 quest motors
white hill business park moulding
there was
a
there was a
no no supplements in that right okay
that's why i got something girly um
catherine could you present report
yeah thank you chairman good evening
members
just worth it
and so this is a
an application for um
which relate to the old quest motor site
on the wick hill business park and it's
for the erection of a mixed-use
development
of comprising class b2
use including an auto center with
vehicle repair mot testing servicing
associated operations
and or specified sui generous uses
um and class e which would be a drive
through coffee shop uses together with
access servicing car parking and
associated works
um
members may recall this application was
deferred at the central area component
committee in july to provide the
applicant an opportunity to address
concerns officers are raised in relation
to parking provision those issues have
now been addressed
so
the proposal has been revised and
additional information has been provided
and the description the proposal has
also been amended to replace the
previous reference to
class b8 uses um with specified serie
generous uses um as the types of usage
proposed not fully for within class b8
and the suede generous uses proposal set
out in the list in your
agenda papers
the application site is located to the
south of malden and is currently vacant
but was last as i've said used by um
quest motors group who operated car
showroom mot testing workshop and from
the site
to the north is
wicks and pets at home
and morrison's supermarket and petrol
filling station is to the east and the
nearest residential property is located
approximately 42 meters to the west on
the opposite side of wick hill
the site is within the settlement
boundary for malden with its western
boundary forming that and that edge of
settlement and there is a public
footpath along the northern boundary the
site
that's a
location plan which
um
is very similar to the one on the on the
first page
um an aerial photo this was when quest
was um
in situ with the uh you see the car
parking there around the edge in the
existing building there central
um these are not that clear to punish
but um these are existing elevations of
the building that that is there
and i've got the existing floor plans
fairly large building
and then we've got a proposed block plan
which will um
so you've got the you've got
three units to the to the north of the
site
um and with the drive-through coffee
shop and um colored in blue to to the
south
with the parking um
around it the vehicle access to the site
would be relocated
um from um
oh yes from approximately
this position here to further up and to
be directly off the roundabout and if
the existing access will be changed into
a footpath
yeah so um what else i've got
so again this is the post parking layout
and which is discussed in the report and
you've got the orange spaces or the
yellow spaces which are policy compliant
in terms of size and then you've got
some additional um
parking spaces in
pink red and there which is slightly
below the stat minimum standard sizes
and then you've got some green ones
which are described as operational
um
and these proposed elevations so this is
unit one
um pretty standard industrial style
commercial style building
and then you've got units two and three
which is one building with two units
inside again very similar designed to
unit one
and then you've got unit four which
would be
your drive-through coffee shop
and the proposed floor plans for units
um
all the units there
and they've got a proposed street scene
which shows the uh
which shows the coffee shop um
here with the
other units um further up the hill
we've got some examples of design
approach to their proposed costa coffee
proposed sections which
shows similar information so that the
section at the
top
is
uh
goes across across the site and so
you've got morrisons to the right there
um
then the the one along the bottom is
then from the
perpendicular
and this was a cgi
provided and prepared by the applicant
to demonstrate what the development
might look like so that would be looking
at it from
um morrison's direction
and you've got so many
photos of the site as it was as quest
and so it's considered that the proposal
would be accessible in principle
and will not cause material harm to the
carriage appearance of the area
furthermore the development would not
cause material harm to local residents
subject to implications of conditions
and no concerns are raised in relation
to highway safety access parking
contaminated land or surface water
drainage and on that basis the
application is recommended for repo
refusal approval and subject to
a number of conditions which are set out
in your agenda paper thank
thank
you
okay um so um i've been asked to
introduce myself so i'm catherine
matthews um specialist development
manager and manager um in specialist
development management
and um i'm the case officer for this um
application and and the other one on
your agenda
and this is i want to introduce yourself
thank you
thank you i'm michael johnson i'm um
lead specialist development management
thank you
thank you thank you um we have
two public participates for this
application
one objector and one agent so we have
the participants for this planning
application in line with the public
participation scheme i now invite them
to read out their submission so i will
go to the objective first mr david
smythe you have two minutes too
i'm representing society
we raised no objection to the workshop
promised the p3 workshop units
we have no
concerns with that
the one aspect that we consider
throughout the rondo is the design and
layer of the cluster coffee building
the first site is travelling into norway
along the floor
fourth of july
will be timber-clad refuse and minster
nigeria with the possibility of over
spilled waste materials to us this is a
proud site
the building at the moment the quest
building is a landmark building who
design building that's valid but it is a
very prominent site
the building in mu would look better if
it was flipped over
elevation iv which you've seen on the
slides to the north
sorry elevation fought to the south but
the reference to interior would be a
better swap for elevation too which is
shown at the other event faced with
works
all the remnants will remain the same
but with a considerably more attractive
innovation facing the main roads
customers out there over a landscaped
area and the uh one of the busiest um
roundabouts in the town with traffic
lights
he offers to report the points that it
would be less visible but not only
nonetheless than more considers of the
layouts video
material
i wouldn't be acceptable
in this position we think that it should
be better than acceptable the good
design if you look at your background
papers could
thank you
i now go to miss sally miles the agent
to
make her presentation
and i'm sonny miles speaking tonight as
the agent on behalf of the developer
hang on can you just wait because we're
just resetting the yeah sorry
you got two 22 seconds there
yes i'm quick but not that quick
i'm speaking to um tonight on behalf of
the developer barbie real estate and we
welcome the case officer's
recommendation for approval this site
has until recently been occupied by
quest motors vehicle dealership which is
now closed the proposals present an
opportunity to secure a high quality
redevelopment of this vacant site
this application was previously
presented to members in july but
determination was deferred to allow last
minute concerns
in respect to parking baywits and lorry
servicing to be fully addressed
since this time we've worked carefully
with the authority to develop a
satisfactory solution to meet the
authority's concerns reducing the amount
of floor space and reconfiguring parking
provision to ensure the majority of
spaces meet the council's preference for
wider bays which are larger than the
national standards
we have also accepted the authority's
request for changes to the description
of development along with conditions
including one for the provision of a
delivery and servicing management plan
to provide officers with comfort that
the proposed development will be
acceptable and controllable we wish to
emphasize that no concerns have been
raised by the authority in relation to
design or the quantum of parking numbers
the only concerns that were raised were
in relation to the size of the bays and
the need to ensure adequate servicing
provision
these have been fully addressed the
scheme has been designed to ensure that
all elevations are attractive and
utilize high quality materials careful
consideration has been taken to devise a
layout that can accommodate a number of
beneficial units the proposals will
deliver up to 35 jobs and further jobs
will be created during the construction
phase
in conclusion it is hoped that members
consider this application favorably it
will deliver a policy compliant high
quality sustainable scheme for a number
of tenants which will provide
significant employment and beneficial
services to the local area
thank you
miss miles um members
do i have any
questions
counselor hurt
um thank you chair um i
i hear what the applicant is saying
about um
the number of
parking spaces has been addressed but
what i do see is that they're still
below
um
that which we expect
i i make it 18 which are below
our standard they might comply with
essex
i think i think they've got 37 at 2.9 by
5.5
the green ones are 2.5 by 5
and the mauve ones are 2.9 by five
so one is perhaps longer and narrower
the other one's narrower and longer
um
why can't we have
um
these spaces where everybody can get out
if you go to morrisons half the time you
can't get out of the car because the
spaces are too small and we know that's
because they extended that and that
therefore it was
that the spaces were squeezed
if you go to other
industrial estates
such as the one down at the causeway you
can get out of the car so here we have
an opportunity
to make
those spaces
and yet it's an opportunity that's been
lost
so when i first looked at this i i i
thought there was three but of course
that relates to one unit but there's
actually 18
18 spaces that are below the standard so
uh i i wondered if if
ms matthews is saying that that's been
addressed it seems to me that it has not
been addressed
um as far as the objective was talking
about um i would be happy to have a
condition that there would be some
screening either through trees
that we put in as a condition
but it's the parking spot broadly i
support the application i don't want to
see an empty building there of course i
want to see jobs they're talking about
uh
28 to 35 full-time jobs well that's
great news
um
but if that's the case out of 55 spaces
that leaves that leaves places for 20
visitors
so if we do if we are going to have
those spaces i'd like to see them so
that people can get out of their cars
thank you councillor heard miss matthews
um yes thank you um the
i'll deal with the the second point
first about the screening that screening
is um does form part of the application
and there is a condition which requires
that screening to be um
provided and implemented
and in terms of the parking spaces um
the
the the
all of the spaces needed to comply with
the standard are the right size um
there's a um i don't know expense in
that in a in a
understandable way so we've got for
units one two and three we've got 19 car
parking spaces all at the minimum size
of 2.9 by 5.5
the other spaces are actually additional
spaces rather than
spaces that are needed to comply with
the standard um
and then unit four they've got 18
parking spaces at the required size 2.9
both 5.5 it's implied with the standard
um
technically they would need to provide
20 car parking spaces
um
but
in addition to those 18 there were also
three parking spaces slightly below the
standard and the further six parking
spaces which are um
quite close to center at two point nine
by five and five meters only slightly
um
missing in the depth right but the width
is is the right width so on that basis
um
you could almost argue they're over
providing they've got more parking
spaces than they actually need in terms
of numbers um
um but the the one the extra spaces
they're providing are are basically um
the ones that are slightly below the
recommended standard and does that
make sense
through you chairman
um i think i would argue the point miss
matthews because
if they're additional ones
why can't we have them then at a proper
size the size that people can get out of
uh it would be better to have
fewer
with spaces that you can actually get
out of a car because if you get if you
get somebody who's either in firm or
pregnant or maybe just overweight
you just can't get out of some of those
spaces and i say time and time again and
with any new builds i would like to see
adequate provision made thank you
thank you councillor head i had
councillor swine and then councillor
morris councillor swine
thank you
chairman um
i recall that
when this came up before exactly
withdrawn before
we had a chance to discuss because the
officers weren't happy with the parking
arrangements so we didn't really get an
opportunity to discuss the projects as a
whole
um just briefly on on two points that
i've mentioned been mentioned so far
um on this question of parking spaces i
mean
quite a few of the parking spaces need
to be big enough for vans
uh not not just for cars so i hope that
has been taken into account
on the point about the
appearance
um coming into the town
um
i i think that is very
important that people see uh have
a good impression on arriving in the
town um i mean on the other side now
when you come up the causeway the whole
your whole vision is dominated by that
very large cost of building and i don't
think that does the town any good
um on this particular part of the town
morrisons is um
well should we say almost in a
vernacular style and very low um low
build
um
and
the the quest existing quest building on
the side as has been actually pointed
out by the um one of the speakers and is
uh quite a striking building in itself
it's a pity that can't be adapted
um
i'm
a little bit uh
perplexed by this chopping and changing
with classes that uh
i want um wanted and why
the change from
b8 to specifying particular uses which
um
all seem to be under b8
and
whether
the
coffee shop
is the only possibility under class e i
don't know whether classy could be
extended to other
um other purposes
um
the two other aspects of this if you've
got these
specified
serie generous um
occupants
how will the um developer actually
ensure that the places are occupied
by um such um activities
um
or are we likely to be left well there's
a developer likely to be left with it um
unused um
premises if they can't be used for these
specific purposes i don't think that's a
planning consideration councillor swine
well it equates the question for ms
matthews about why the
changing about the definitions of the
classes
applied but my um
over
a riding
issue is um
that the the driving coffee idea seems
to be totally
um
unrelated to
what otherwise is simply an addition to
the business park
and i can't see the value of that um
why that should be incorporated in this
this development here
um it's going to be the main
um producer of traffic from this site
much more than you obviously get at the
moment
or have had with crest motors
um so i i
i am not at all happy with the inclusion
of the drive-through coffee idea in this
what is uh otherwise a business estate
thank you council so miss matthews
um yes thank you
let me just look um
so in terms of the uses
the the type of use that
um the developer was hoping to
um sell or or these these buildings to
places like um
tool station
um
and
which
because the class ba is storage and
distribution but a tool station
is
no it doesn't fall soundly within class
b8 it's not not just
um storage and distribution certainly
these days there is an element of um
uh
general use by the by the general public
rather than just trade um
so
these sort of new uses like screw fix as
well they've sort of moved in in office
of una they moved
moved out of class b8 um and into more
of a mixed type use um and therefore
that's why we've
talked to them about including
um a list of suigenerous uses um
rather than just a general class b8
because the class b8 use was causing
issues in terms of
um providing lorry parking so if it was
a standard nor perhaps more traditional
class v8 use and there wasn't going to
be any lorry parking um
and that we thought was going to cause a
conflict um so that was partly to help
resolve that issue
so the and the list of uses that is on
your papers that's what the developer
has asked for it's not what we've come
up with that is the list that they think
will be
sufficiently wide and um
to um
cover all the types of uses or the
interest they've had in the site
um
so that that is conditions that it will
only be be those uses that's not to say
that no other use could ever be there
just mean that the council would have
still retained
control over it and they would need to
ask before a different use went in there
so it wouldn't necessarily mean that the
premises would be left empty
they would
other uses could be um considered but
they would need to come to the council
first and ask and if we thought it was
the council thought it was
okay then and didn't cause any issues
that um or any harm then
a different type of use could be
permitted
and
in terms of the coffee shop and class e
classic is a new youth class um
which he's
has incorporated quite a few used
classes that
that used to exist so that includes
shops and
some offices and then
a a very wide
in some way worryingly wide scope for
for uses um
the coffee shop a coffee shop a
drive-through coffee shop would fall
within class e
and but so with lots of other types of
uses um
so there is a condition recommended that
it that building shall only be used as a
coffee shop and and again that doesn't
necessarily mean no other operator or
occupier could could
use the premises but they would need to
ask first and then make an application
to
to vary the condition so that other
occupiers could could move into there if
if a coffee shop drive through coffee
shop was no longer
required or there's no longer demand for
that um
in terms of the relation of the driving
coffee shop to the business part that is
addressed
in the report and um
it's
it was felt that the that
the cost of coffee would
be a complimentary use to the business
park um
there would be it would a lot of the
custom would come from the the people
who worked in in the business park and
there is there is a retail type element
on the louis park with wicks and pets at
home we've also got morrison's opposite
and it also in terms of the business
park as a whole it was quite a small
area of the site
and therefore um we felt that it would
it would be acceptable on on that basis
as a
support of a small supporting or
complementary role within the business
park um
and wouldn't wouldn't be out of keeping
or um
at odds with with the the existing uses
and the proposed uses in in the
immediate area
i think that and that will respond to
most of your concerns but um happy to
answer any more questions if if not
thank you
can i come back on one or two version um
can i go to councillor morris first and
then
you sure
okay council is fine
councillor morris has said that you can
go first council this way
um
yes i'm a little bit disturbed from what
miss matthews has said um
uh
i can see value in a um
a place on a business park that provides
some food refreshments and and so on um
but this is specifically down as a
drive-through
um so if it's used by people on the
business part they're going to be
walking in and in fact from what um ms
matthews has said
um
you could get um the public coming in to
um access
other activities there um
you mentioned tool station and
or a similar activity um but i it could
apply to another these are some of these
others which have
a trade
um access and a
a retail aspect i'm not quite sure that
we could actually
um uh police that
um
so
a
a a catering location in a business park
is fine but that seems to be quite in
conflict with the idea of a
drive-through which is for people who
are not in the business part basically
thank you
do you want to turn your mic off thank
you
thank you just just one small comment in
relation to that um
i
i think well i i can envisage that no
people who might drive to
tool station might also use cross coffee
and the coffee coffee isn't just a
drive-through there is
no parking spaces for people to go
inside and use used cost costa coffee
and to get um a takeaway in in in the
way
in the more traditional way i suppose um
so there i there would definitely be the
scope there for um
multi-purpose trips um and there weren't
there may i'm sure there would be some
people who would only go to the costa
coffee but with the the retail units and
um you've got morrisons and and
tall station if that's what happens and
got formula one so you know for example
formula one while people were having
their car repaired at formula one they
could go to cost coffee and get get get
get a drink or some refreshments so so i
think there is a link a link there
between um
the uses that are proposed um
but yes there will be people who just go
to costa coffee but um i think there
there is um certainly a significant
element of uh what there would be it
would be complementary and it would
support the um the businesses that uh
the other business on the on the um
on the business park at the moment and
and those that are proposed thank you
chairman that does seem to indicate
much greater demand really for parking
spaces
up beyond what has been um
scheduled for businesses actually on the
premises
thank you councillors
mr johnson
bob thank you chairman i just really
wanted to sort of echo what
um miss matthews mrs matthews was saying
um
particularly around the complementary
use issue i mean that is
i think
most of us
might realize or if we think about it
the complementary use in
retail parks is very much a feature of
retail tale parks
these days
the interconnectedness using one or
going visiting for one use and making
use of another
is very much a generator of business and
i think that as a model that sometimes
has generally been accepted
um you know in my experience having the
complementary use is very much something
that
features in terms of our employment
areas or formerly
wholly employment areas
it's on this basis and having regard to
that as a model up and down the country
and also reflected generally in planning
considerations is why there is a support
for the complementary use and then the
other issues as well is
how does the complementary use detract
from the
employment area although it's not a
designated employment area it's got a
history of employment use on the site
um the
proposals
um
which are in front of us the siri
generous if you want to put it
type uses um provide a range of uses
which
um will support and assist in the
diversification
within the employment area
it could potentially attract a whole
range of um businesses um
uh that could fall within the sui
generous model or
if they don't fall within the surrey
generous model it's something that we
can consider on an application from the
applicants so that does give us a whole
range rather than
um
constraining the type of operations that
could go there
um
from the planning
authority's view that that is a positive
role
where we can consider the
interconnectedness that the various uses
that can go there and how that in itself
can be a generator for a successful
business park
um yeah and then i suppose the other
thing again is in terms of parking
um
what mrs matthews has stressed is that
there is a nova provision of park in
here while some of the parking spaces
may not be to standard
i think we all recognize that you know
you know the cars we drive on of a
particular standard there's a whole
range of cars a whole range of people
that visited in different types of
vehicles
um i'm just touching on some of the
points was uh councillor heard was
mentioning before in terms of
you know can you get in and out your
cars that sort of thing partly yeah it
may be the person themselves but it's
also the type of car that that you
actually drive
um
there's a short fall of i think two or
three parking spaces mrs matthews
mentioned
in terms of the minimum standard
required for the entire development and
what and the
the variety in the sizes based around
2.9 times 5
or
or 2.5 times was it five
some kind of variation around around
those numbers
that to me in terms of the over
provision is is more than acceptable in
providing a variety of spaces which
accepts that there are a whole variety
of vehicles that use these business
parts um
the key thing is in terms of
is there an impact in terms of the loss
of overall employment space from a
planning point of view um is there a
is there a material under provision of
of parking space uh
reflective of that employment space i
would argue that on balance there isn't
that case and that's how this has been
this has been supported and i think in
addition in terms of
uh
vehicle movements to the site um
the highway authority is quite clear
that um
although there will be an increase in
traffic and i think that that will be
expected
um it satisfies the requirements it
meets the test within the mppf it is not
considered severe
um which is um the yardstick to which
whether
a development will have a significant
impact on the local highway network that
is not the case here
that is also reflected in the
applicant's
traffic study
of the development so there is
quantifiable and robust information in
that sense
um which
if i'm
maybe understanding
some elements of where you may be going
with this counselor's reign and i do
appreciate that it's not born out in
terms of the assessments and and the
evidence
thank you chairman thank you
council maurice thank you for waiting
thank you very much um
i'm aware that what i'm about to say
isn't a material planning consideration
but it would have been really nice um to
have a different coffee operator because
i think that's the fourth cost of coffee
malden's got we really need that um i
wish we'd
be able to give
the independence and the small
businesses uh more um more of a bite of
the cake
um
i wonder if uh we can use that coffee at
the capers awake while we're ringing for
doctors because uh you know getting a
doctor surgery somewhere down there
would have been absolutely excellent but
yet again not material planning
consideration
and i would like to propose that we
accept the officer's recommendations but
with the condition put in that the
gentleman behind me from the malden
society um uh flagged up earlier um i
have to ask for a seconder
thank you councillor morris i do have
councillor shaunicy and councillor lagan
to
present uh to ask a question but do i
have a second of the council of morris's
proposal
council morris can you turn your mic off
there is no seconder for that proposal
yet uh councillor shauna say
sorry chair thank you
i also have a bit of a problem with the
drive through coffee shop
because um i'm sure i read somewhere
that it's going to be open from five in
the morning until 2300 hours please tell
me i'm wrong because that does seem
you know ludicrous a ludicrously long
time and
that would generate many cups of coffee
now we do not want a litter
problem in this area
we definitely don't
and i would like that all those um
coffee cups to be made of recyclable
material
and sufficient bins for those recyclable
material cups to be put in so that they
can go to a different place than
landfill because um the generation of
all this all these coffee cups you know
and if they're not recyclable will be a
huge um addition to landfill and i think
we as councillors
really don't need that so i would like
um some um
someone to speak on that and reassure me
please thank you chairman thank you miss
matthews
um thank you um
the proposed hours for the drive-through
coffee shop are 5 a.m to 11 p.m monday
to sunday that's what the
applicant has asked for so yes
um you're right that the hours are be as
long as you had read somewhere um
in terms of the litter
potential problem
and
recycling cups um recycle ball cups
um i would suggest that that goes beyond
the powers of a local planning authority
um
i don't know
dr michael whether he um agrees or not
um
yeah so uh that would be something that
um would be up for the i mean we can add
uh an informative maybe to um point the
applicant in in in that direction but i
think that is something that's happening
um
anyway through
other legislation and another and public
pressure for um for more green
approaches to
business
um so thank you
that's the show
probably the only thing i would add to
that is that um
costa coffee as
an operator do have other
legislation that they have to comply
with in terms of how they operate in
terms of
um any litter
that may be generated as a result
of their operations so it's not just the
planning permission that controls some
of the elements that um that you've
mentioned
i'm i'm not aware of any um
at least through the local authority
powers that can control
the
type of material they use in their cops
although very much i appreciate it and i
think you know we're all on board with
that but in terms of specific controls
um
you know probably the most we can do is
as as catherine mentioned is probably
probably informative
for the applicants to use their best
endeavors in terms of you know
recyclable materials or something of
that sort of nature but that would only
be through an informative but in terms
of litter there are other controls um
that that are in place and that they
would have to adhere to if that can
give you some some sort of measure of
comfort in that respect
counselor
thank you chairman just very briefly um
yes i would like something along those
lines that miss matthews has suggested
to be put forward please thank you so
much and i'd like that minute thank you
thank you councillor lagan
thanks chad there's just a couple of
things listening to the debate and
the first one is um that something needs
to happen so that's why excuse me um
but we all understand that and what
council morris says about doctor surges
he's quite right um but that's what
we're talking about at the moment um
things that concern me and i don't know
whether these are material planning
considerations but they our concerns are
um do we go far enough in the
environmental impact of the development
um i think we we've declared a climate
emergency as a council and this is a
golden opportunity to uh excel maybe
having green living plant walls added to
it solar panels heat exchange pumps all
of those things that could could be put
in um to help make the the impact on the
environment lesser
um i'm very disappointed by what you
said mr johnson by saying parking spaces
below the standard but that's okay why
should we
have our buildings and developments
below our standard
why can't we set a standard why can't we
be different the built environment we
can't continue the way that we're going
on the way that we just accept what i
consider and i will clarify this i speak
on nobody's behalf apart from my own but
over development of this brilliant town
so we've got to start to think
differently and i think if we could work
with the developer for an opportunity to
look at things in a different way we can
set higher benchmarks than just meeting
a standard
i welcome the fact that we're going to
get some employment opportunities down
there for malden
we need it desperately but i think we
shouldn't let things slip below a
standard i think we should look outside
of the box and i i would say again i am
disappointed by saying that we think you
know
things cause harm and we can let it slip
a little bit below the standard and cars
are all different shapes and sizes i
ride a push bike most of the time you
know that suits me so formula one is
probably not a place i'll be going down
to um and i also think that costa coffee
has such a dominant presence in our town
um and as councillor morris has said we
don't see eyes why on many things but
this we absolutely do the independent
coffee shops in our town should be given
a chance to have something of this
nature because other opportunities are
not available for them they deserve to
have what i would call a premium site
coming into the town offered to them
i don't know if that can be done
you know it can exist or costas have got
it helpline and sinker but i think we're
missing out on really supporting the
businesses in our town thank you
thank you council
i've got a question for you miss mathews
how many eevee parking spaces are there
i will have to have a look at the plan
and count them but they're there they
are there and they are enough
to um comply with the uh standard that
was something that was
um made a point of including i can cut
them if you wanted it but it would be
nice because with the fact that we're
trying to push electric vehicles
the more ev spaces we've got in this
town
the better
councillor heard
sorry
mr matthews
response
yeah sorry i welcome that thank you
thank you sorry cancellation
yeah just
probably starting on um probably the
easiest for me uh would be in terms of
um the um sort of market competition and
and
i don't know you know how many
variations around costa you know uh
operations do you have
um how can we manage that how can we
control that can that be through the
planning system
um the answer to that is no we we cannot
impact in terms of uh market
competitions
um if it's costs are coming through we
can't say well there's a threshold for
costas and there must be some allowance
for other similar operations
i have sympathy for that but that's one
of the things that's always been
discussed from time immemorial through
planning we just can't control that
um in terms of in terms of the parking
standards um i'd like to think that my
comments weren't
considered or heard to be kind of
laissez faire about about parking
conditions
um just to take to take uh you sorry in
the plural yeah uh back to the when the
original application came here all the
parking sizes were undersized and that
potentially was going to be a reason for
refusal for that scheme
um
although uh in the in in the
consideration of that theme there were
some sort of
two in and throw in look at the type of
uh units that were proposed and the the
type of vehicles they would generate and
that sort of thing
um but that's the position we had gone
to so very much we'd been taken on on
into consideration the size of
of parking base um
as having to meet our our standards
with this scheme and um i'll have to
defer to miss
matthews for the um exact numbers but
there is only a
an under provision of two or three
parking spaces for the minimum required
for the
size of units for this premises and
there are i think it was it was it 18
you you counted
catherine
in terms of the additional spaces over
the minimum standards so it's it's not
a kind of less a fair approach towards
this and the development can almost sort
of have what what they want
um
we're talking about a reduction of 0.5
in one of the dimensions or or or so in
the over provision
uh i think you know when we make our
planning recommendations or decisions
uh it has to be based on material
considerations we do have to weigh up a
whole number of factors
and the provision of
an additional 18 parking spaces am i
correct in
an additional 18 parking spaces over the
minimum although they some of them may
be undersized we think is a is a is a is
a
you know i think it's a plus for the
scheme um and definitely not the local
authority capitulating to the developers
standards
um
i think since the application was
deferred back in july
there's been significant discussions
about how this matter can be resolved
which is why we're here today with this
particular recommendation otherwise it
would have been a refusal previously
um and your i think your first point was
around
um
pushing the boundaries in a sense in
terms of environmental credentials and
solar panels and that sort of thing
um
i mean in a way there's
we would have to have specific policies
for us to be able to
um ask for uh
a quota or a percentage or whatever
different authorities try and approach
it in different ways in terms of major
developments for example and what can be
provided or if it's large residential
developments
we do have an spd
where we allude to that
um but we don't have the policy backing
on that as yet
um so
there was no
sort of legal
or policy basis for us to be able to
insist on some of these matters we don't
have that criteria
and
you know although the mppf also which we
can rely on makes references to that
it's largely how we push that through
the plan making process to be able to
then implement it at the development
management stage so i think we're just
at this position here with all the
debate going on nationally um globally i
would say around these matters that it's
difficult for us at this moment through
these day-to-day applications to
implement some of these things unless
it's set through policy thank you
chairman
councillor can i just come back very
quickly thank you for that that helps me
understand an awful lot mr johnson
and the parking space is still
undersized
over provision we're still undersized
i'm not having to pop up the developer
in any way shape or form
the local authority will make the
decision
based on that the local authority needs
to keep his standards
and i also feel that by going to
the developers and saying okay we can't
enforce you know you'd be clear with the
environmental impact on that there's
nothing wrong with going and saying
we want some net positive gain
because it's all about material harm how
we mitigate that i'm not teaching you
psychics you're far more verse than i am
but we've we've accepted harm for far
too long
we have opportunities to work with
developers to build something that can
help everybody
so we might not be able to put it
through in policy
but i'm very very disappointed that
we're not starting to look outside the
box a bit more on developments such as
this
and i get what you say about local
people not being cared about but having
an opportunity because it's not in a
planning policy framework
and that's sad
but thank you thank you councillor if
you don't mind council herd and swan
councillor mate hasn't spoken yet and
i'd like to go to councillor mays
thank you madam chairman um yeah i've
listened very carefully and um i take on
board exactly where you come from um
cancer lag and with with the parking
spaces and standards
um
i think somebody said earlier i would
rather see
two
less but of the standard
than 18.
i don't want to see 18. 18 is over
i want to see them all the same so if i
drive on there as an employee i can park
in any parking space and i know my car's
going to fit
i don't have to go around searching
because they won't be purple spaces they
won't be green spaces i'm not going to
be able to tell when i drive into that
site
what size those spaces are but i still
got my car
um going back to your point uh madam
chairman about um ev points there are
three for the site um i'm not entirely
sure that they're actually on the cart
on the
cafes site um but uh it looks like
they're on the
um
the other part of the site so the the
industrial
part of the site um but but perhaps you
could clarify that that's at
3.7 point one seven it says that there
are three and you're ready somewhere um
three car parking ev points um again i'd
like to see at least one of those to be
in the in the in the coffee drive
through
area um as well even if it's and also
i'm going to ask the question is are
these um destination ones or are they
fast charged
big difference
um i'm happy with destination ones
uh you know i've done some of my
homework on on ev points and i'm very
happy with destination once um thank you
madam chairman thank you
thank you uh
yes there are three
um ev
um parking spaces shown on the drawing
um and in the transport statement it
also says there are three additional
spaces
which um have been identified for um
which could be used for
also um charging in the future
um those three spaces that they have
shown that which were provided at the
outset
are within the northern part of the site
and there aren't any within the
um the
drive-through coffee shop part of the
site that is something which could i'm
sure be
easily dealt with by a condition if
if that's the way members were going to
go with it and the um the charting
points would be fast charging points
yeah
thank you
the council heard
well i was going to make a proposal
chairman
having listened to all the things that
have been said
and my proposal is that we that we
do accept the officer's recommendation
subject to
all of the car parking spaces being
2.9 by 5.5
if it means losing a couple
then so then so be it
but i think all of them should comply
um i also think that it should be a
condition that at least one
electric charging point is at
the coffee
area
and i think
i think i think with those two i'd be
happy to to agree this
that seconded
yes
um can you tell me michael sorry
i did have a a proposal from councillor
morris which was to accept the officer's
recommendations without any conditions
um
was that seconded
no
okay so i've now got
i want councillor swine you've just
yeah can i raise my two points
um we've got two proposals on the table
councillor swain and i would like to
move this
on
so
i think i've got loads of hands going up
it's
just to complete the discussion of the
issue really um
on
as a small rejoinder to mr johnson on
the retail parts i agree with what what
he says about um
uh should we say the combination of
activities adding to it it was a sort of
synergy of it
but i'll just point out there is no
other public parking in that area uh any
anybody coming as a an outsider but i'd
have to park use it but park in there or
use use morrisons um
that what we haven't covered is
what um what is the extent of any
sit-down accommodation in the costa
coffee um
well
i mean it's talking about drive through
but also surely they would cater for
people to stay there and and eat um
is there an
accommodation for that
and my last point is surely can we not
what we're going to have to do in the
future is i've got a point of order
thank you
debate it's finished then the the two
proposals that have been tabled so these
points that should be negated should be
thank you councillor nan our second
councillor heard's proposal thank you
i had the proposal from councillor heard
to accept this with two conditions the
one that is that the parking spaces are
all the same size
2.9 by 5.5
yeah
um
i was just going to um
perhaps um i'm just trying to think
through the implications of that so this
is the parking layout that's been
proposed so say the yellow ones are the
right
right side the standards meet the
standard and then we've got the these
pink ones here which
are smaller
i can't see from here what the
dimensions are
can i just make it so i'll just make a
point sharon that yeah
if if if i had a transit van which i do
not it would leave me with one foot of
door opening space if i had a mini which
i do not it would leave me with 385
millimeters it's just not enough on
those minimum standards sorry okay so um
so with these spaces down here for
example um you you
the developer wouldn't be able to make
them longer
um the right standard without in without
interfering with the access way or
going into the um the landscape area
along the front
both of which i would suggest would be a
retrograde step and something that as
officers we wouldn't have encouraged
so by saying that all the spaces need to
be the right size then one possible
implication of that would be that there
wouldn't be any spaces down here for
them because there wouldn't be there
wouldn't be enough space to put them in
as the right size particularly because
of the depth if they could make them um
i think they are the right wit but if
they were the men weren't the right wic
they could have
space them out a bit more and uh got a
few number in but because it's the the
depth issue that's the problem there
then
they uh they
they can't do it so that that would
potentially mean that those spaces
wouldn't be provided at all
um
and then the green spaces are the ones
that are and the the smallest spaces
and these these spaces are appear um my
point of gone then these three here they
were they were designed to be um
they're operational spaces and there the
idea of those is that people going to
have their mot done um would know it'd
be somewhere that they
wouldn't necessarily
be used by the customer but the
customers cars might be kept there while
they were waiting to be done later in
the day for example um
and and the same over on the other side
there's some six spaces here which are
operational spaces um
but again if if if it does it's not
going to work um into not enough space
around them to make them bigger then
they would be lost so you wouldn't get
any any extra spaces
um and then you've got three down three
um small spaces down here
which um again
that there wouldn't be the scope for
making them any bigger than they already
are without um encroaching into the
access way
and and all the pedestrian
access through through the site so um if
that's members preference then i just
want you to
um if you like make make sure that you
were aware of what the implications are
it's all very well saying and put a
condition on and and then they would
need to comply with it but i just want
to make sure that everyone understands
what the implications of that might be
and
it might and just to make sure it is
going to achieve what you're hoping it
will achieve and not have some perhaps
unexpected consequences which if you
perhaps been aware of them at the time
you might have thought twice about going
down that line that road um
but that thank you that was all i was
going to um
well if i could come back on that i mean
you either have a policy or we don't
and if we start doing this then we can
do it elsewhere and then we'll have
slightly smaller spaces elsewhere and i
think uh the way vehicles are
these days is i'm afraid that they are
built bigger and i think we should be
accommodating that and it's clear when
you go down to other other uh retail
sites
you know it's easy to get in and out of
the car and in places like morrison's it
isn't and
if
if we carry on building these smaller
places
it's just going to make going there
um off-putting by people but we've
either got a standard or we haven't and
i think we should have that standard if
it means losing a space
these are as you've said there are 18
additional spaces so okay we have 16
additional spaces but there's still
enough to go around that's my view
and i think
um what i suppose what i'm trying to say
in perhaps a roundabout way is i think
it's going to be more than two spaces
that will be lost um
we don't know exact number and i was
also going to suggest that if members
want to go down that line i think the
condition perhaps should ask for a
revised parking layout with all spaces
the right size that we've got an
opportunity to say
to assess it rather than just say all
the spaces would be the right size and
let them sort it out for themselves um i
think that would be the more
safer way of feeling like that's not the
way but the better way of doing it thank
you well chad i'm i'm content with that
if other members are
yes i'd be happy to amend my second of
that uh proposal
uh councilmember you did put your hand
up
yeah thank you madam chairman um i've
had another look at the plan um
currently the area as you come into the
i think there's a per the purple um on
the screen
um there's a bit in front of it which is
designated as green space
um
we have to face fact that this is an
industrial area
can't get away from that currently
there's no planting there currently
there's no planting
we could perhaps look to add some
additional planting elsewhere within the
site might might be but in order to
actually make those
bays big enough we're going to have to
compromise
and that's what this is about and
actually use that piece of land as well
unless the developer suggests that there
are reasons that we can't however coming
back to what then ms matthews then said
i think her suggestion is very um
sensible going forward with a a proposal
to actually give us a layout
thank you i make that condition thank
you
mr
um yeah uh thank you chairman i mean i'm
i think i'm i'm personally i'm actually
starting to have a bit of concerns about
us um
almost redesigning this scheme um app
committee
um
the proposal um
in front of us is what's for
consideration
um
we are looking at
a fundamental change of the scheme it's
not just the addition of you know half a
half a meter um
on
uh parking bays that may not be to those
size here um
this is a this is a a model which the
the applicant has has worked on
um since the last committee back in july
and the scheme has been significantly
revised as a result of that
um
you know this is not something which um
you know there's been any discussion
with with them on this would impact on
their business model i think that this
goes to the essence of what they're
proposing um as a scheme
in a whole
and it may well be the question for
members that
if
they're not happy with the scheme
as it is
and given the changes the fundamental
change that would be required
to achieve what members want
it may be that
members may have to consider
maybe recommend the screen for refusal
if that's the case
i mean this isn't i mean but where we
where we add conditions um
um to a scheme it's normally with the
agreement with the with the applicant it
may be something that probably just gets
them over the edge if that's the sort of
thing yeah
or it may be
some sort of mitigation which
is is is clear and openly reasonable
i i i'm a bit concerned about this
approach here
thank you
councillor langan well you can be as
concerned with all due respect as you
like this is our town and we're trying
to make the right decisions for the town
for going forward for the future so i i
certainly wouldn't be in a position
where i felt i could not recommend
approval based on the changes in the
recommendations
i think the applicant wants to to get
this over the line i think with very
small changes it's not like redesigning
the whole thing and as councilor mays
has said very small changes would be
made
and that way we could meet all legal
requirements that are set down within
there and also make sure that we have
areas that are acceptable for vehicle
users to to use you know mothers in
their push chairs people with
disabilities need bigger space
i think i think it was only right and
proper that we should look at that for
the benefit of our town and for
sustainability going forward mr johnson
thank you thank you councillor langan
i'm going to go very quickly to
councillor morris and then i'm going to
come back to miss councillor herd
councillor morris
um just to point out that uh voice of
reason would say that if the car parking
spaces are too small people will just
encroach into the next one so they'll
make their own parking base thank you
councillor heard you have put a proposal
on the table which has been seconded um
which was to recommend
approval but with conditions are you
still happy to make that
chairman i am thank you
and councillor nan are you still happy
to second that i am sure thank you okay
so we do have that recommendation so
that was for approval but with
conditions on the spaces for car parking
being all the same
and maybe losing some car parking spaces
and
mrs matthews suggested that that scheme
comes back for the officers to look at
the other condition was to have more ev
parking space uh charging spaces i think
it was at least one where the
by the coffee unit thank you so
that is the recommendation council
amazed very quickly yes uh sorry miss
madden chairman um the
yeah you know sorry i wasn't wasn't
going to talk about i'd say about that
um the the decision um needs to come
back for agreement with at least the uh
the chairman um of of this committee
thank you thank you
so
you have that recommendation before you
all those in favor of that
recommendation
okay
thank you those against
and i'm gonna abstain
so that has now
carried
thank you so that motion has been
carried we will move on to item
six thank you members of the public
we will move on to item six on the
agenda which is found on page 33-46
so we move on to item six of the agenda
found on pages
33 to 46 which is 2100
646 full barn at malden white
spittle road moulder
there was no additional paperwork so i
will call on mrs matthews to present the
rebel
councilor none sorry
um just before miss matthew starts on
this chair i understand why item five
was brought to this committee because
it's a major development
i don't understand why item six is a
committee for a single barn conversion
the reason that's given is it's not
delegated to officers and i don't
understand that term
thank you miss smith yes yeah um through
chairman um it's a
technically it's a departure from the
local plan because it's a house outside
the development boundary of malden
and which we don't thank you
miss matthews would you like to present
it sorry it would be helpful chair in
future if that could be stated yes
thank you
from the drop there was a drop down list
from our standard committee report
template which um i
been told off for changing in the past
so i would select the one that's the
most appropriate from the list
um but maybe that will be uh but noted
yes
um
okay
thank you chairman
so this is an application um for the
conversion of a barn into a residential
dwelling with alterations in a new
carport this shows the location of the
application site and the hospital road
is down here um in the bottom right hand
corner
um
so the the barn is in the ground of the
malden wick approximately 10 meters to
the north of existing house of molten
wick which is um just below the arrow
there
and molten wick is located hospital road
i said and accessed by a private drive
the barn subject the application and the
existing house at modern week are both
great to listed buildings
um
okay
so that's the location um slightly
zoomed out
an aerial view
and this is a proposed block plan which
shows the existing building the barn to
be converted and the proposed detached
cart lodged to the south east
and the cot lodge would have an external
staircase
and these are the elevations
existing and proposed
of the barn
and then these are the floor plans for
the barn on the left hand side there and
the elevations of the
cart lodge um on the top right hand
corner and the
floor plan for the cart lodge on the
bottom right corner
um
so these are some photos of the barn um
as it is
again different photos and different
angles
so it's um considered the proposal um is
acceptable in principle and would not
have an adverse impact on the character
appearance of the area the integrity of
the listed building or the setting of
neighbouring listed buildings subject to
the imposition of conditions which are
recommended the proposal would also not
have an adverse impact on the immunity
of neighboring residential properties
nature conservation or parking um or
highway safety and adequate quality of
life for the occupiers of the dwelling
would also be provided and it's worth
perhaps noting at this point that this
proposal is
all for all intents purposes that the
same as um an application that was
previously um submitted and approved and
that that was um that ran out of time i
think went beyond the three years so
this is the main reason why they've had
to resubmit now and the other little
comment i was going to make was that the
the associated listed building
application and consent application for
the current application for the current
proposal has has already been granted um
and without didn't uh that could be done
under delegated powers but um this this
planning application departure i
couldn't and therefore it's before you
this evening thank you
councillor morris
this looks like a very attractive
property um but i think we should
accept the officer's proposal and give
it the go ahead okay
thank you i will come back to that
proposal well and let us have our debate
can you turn your mic off i did thank
you
so
councillor swain
yes thank you chairman um can you care
if i can mrs matthews clarify the
listing situation
uh whether these buildings themselves
are listed or whether they're
part of a what you say associated with a
listed building and if so does that have
an impact on the
manner and the manner of the conversions
and the materials to be used
um the both the the barn the subject
this application and the neighbouring
modern wick are individually listed
um
they're not personally listed as um
mr johnson just suggested and yes and it
very definitely does have an impact on
on what's allowed there and the proposal
has been designed in a way that has
satisfied the um
specialist conservation heritage um
and there are conditions
recommended which um reflect his advice
in terms of materials
um
and then the applications is detailed
it's got i haven't put on the
presentation but there's there's been a
timber survey of the building done and
the the uh design is felt to be um in
keeping with the
the the building um and it is it will be
altered but the alterations wouldn't um
harm it as a as a listed building or
maintain its integrity thank you thank
you
any other member
any questions
can i ask miss matthews has the rams
is there a rams on this
uh dear chairman yes there is a iran's
contribution um
generated by the proposal because it's a
new dwelling and um
the rams payment has been already paid
and there is also a
united undertaking a legal agreement to
secure that payment along with the
monetary fee and the um
the checking fee so that that issue has
all been um adequately addressed thank
you good
counsellor now
second the proposal on the table thank
you thank you so members there is a
proposal on the table to accept the
officer's recommendation for approval
that has been julie seconded councillor
yes subject to the conditions subject to
the conditions yes that has been duly
seconded by councillor none
uh all those in favour
that's unanimous
item seven on the agenda any other items
that the chairman decides urgent there
are none so therefore i close this
meeting at
8 45.
thank you members as this meeting is now
closure about is not to enter into any
further discussion and please leave the
meeting by the exit floor behind the top
table bearing in mind social distancing
thank you
okay